und jetzt möchte ich mit einem
augenzeugen aus dieser nacht reden
unternehmer matthias groß saß beim
abendessen und wurde dann zeuge der
ereignisse in stuttgart heroe guten tag
und vielleicht können sie uns schildern
wo und was haben sie gesehen in dieser
nacht in stuttgart also jetzt möchte ich
sagen dass stuttgart bekannt ist als das
größte beschauliche dorf deutschland
weil wir den eindruck in stuttgart das
ist das epizentrum der gewalt geworden
ist gestern herrschten in der stadt
biggs englisch hier zustände
es wurde auf die polizei mit steinen die
stühle alles geworfen
es wurden demoliert und straßen
aufgerissen die steile ausgerollt auf
die polizisten geworfen
man konnte richtig angst bekommen wir
hatten angst wir haben sie sich dann in
dieser situation verhalten
nun ich will nach hause gegangen weil
mein bruder auch auf die farbe von der
polizei über sollte die straße lassen
sollte nach hause gehen muss sollte sich
schützen weil es war in der ganzen stadt
jeder ecke gab es ausschreitungen
es war unglaublich was geht da in ihrem
herzen vor
man hört in dem was sie schildern sie
sind von herzen stuttgarter fühlen sich
verbunden mit dieser stadt wenn sie dann
ihre stadt zu erleben müssen
es ist grausam wir lieben unsere stadt
die stuttgarter haben alle ihre stadt
und diese zustände die jetzt herstellen
das ist nicht vergessen und so wir haben
in den letzten wochen öfters
ausschreitungen in ähnlichem maße in
stuttgart gehabt wo es ausschließlich
darum geht der polizei zu schaden und
das team haben wir an stocker in der
zukunft sie stehen jetzt auch in der
innenstadt können sie uns einen eindruck
vermitteln wie jetzt da die stimmung ist
in der stadt ist gerade friedlich es ist
alles aufgeräumt
es sind viele leute da die natürlich
durch die königstraße laufen und die
ganze schäden begutachten
aber ansonsten es ist wieder eine
demonstration da und es geht ganz normal
weiter meine letzte frage an sie herr
ruhe setzen sie sich heute abend wieder
in ihr lieblingsrestaurant und essen
draußen oder würden sie sich das heute
eher nicht trauen wollten compo dann
herzlichen dank und ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen abend